c'est l'heure des adieux dans le décor
de Plus belle la vie
l'équipe du feuilleton partage ce moment
sur les réseaux sociaux en ce dernier
jour de tournage les fans attendent à
l'entrée des studios pour dire au revoir
à leurs acteurs favoris une bouffée
d'émotions on n'arrive pas à se dire que
c'est fini voilà c'est pas possible ils
font avec nous ils font partie de notre
vie et c'est très c'est très difficile
pour nous
les deniers de l'écran redevance ah bah
profitez-en c'est le moment où jamais
d'enterrer la redevance télé au revoir
la redevance
et à ton âme la redevance télé qui nous
a accompagné pendant des années en
espérant que l'année prochaine nous ne
présenterons pas cela mon fond d'une
cave éclairée par des bougies ce n'est
qu'une question de confiance tout est
une question de confiance la vie est une
question de confiance au début moi pour
muscler donc ce muscle de la gratitude
c'est que je marchais et en marchant je
disais merci la vie merci la vie merci
la vie et du coup ma marche était
beaucoup plus rapide et ça rentrait ça
pénétrer mes cellules on est vraiment
des extraterrestres sur ce plateau
bonjour monsieur il manque un euro pour
acheter une glace non
j'ai pas du tout mon cœur merci bonjour
excuse-moi il me manque un euro pour
acheter ma glace non merci il manque un
euro pour acheter ma glace
bien sûr oui
vous saviez donc quand siffle
quand on vous appelle
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un qui vous embête
pour de vrai quelqu'un qui vous accoste
cela arrive il ne faut pas que ce soit
l'extrême d'un viol par exemple c'est
juste on ne peut pas avancer dans sa
journée sans que quelqu'un vous embête
changement de méthode et si j'essayais
en blonde cette fois je me suis rendu
dans un salon de coiffure parisien pour
me faire poser une perruque et vous
allez le voir j'ai beaucoup plus de
chance bonjour monsieur excusez-moi il
me faudrait 1 euro pour acheter une
glace il me manque un euro et pas direct
merci beaucoup
les gens sont généreux aujourd'hui
excusez-moi il manque euros pour acheter
une glace oui ah c'est gentil
attention Nikos
Dalida les femmes sont des juges
surtout et on se compare tout le temps
c'est ça le problème des femmes c'est
vrai mais si moi je me suis pas comparer
avec vous hein
ouais c'est ça alors Anne Nelson et Alex
vous savez faire ça ou pas je viens
d'essayer sans succès
toi non mais moi je fais je fais ça dans
l'intimité
et c'est pas le seul truc que tu fais
dans la timidité alex je suis consterné
par cette affirmation que vous venez de
faire
[Applaudissements]
voyagé dernièrement en classe et qu'on a
les images de son arrivée
voilà
on voit bien
on voit bien c'est parce que on voit
bien que c'est ainsi un siège business
c'est pas bien de se moquer des
camarades je trouve que vous rayez plus
qu'aux autres blagues bisous
moi j'ai fait deux jours garde à vue
c'est que dalle c'est rien du tout on
n'a pas foutu un pied en prison et on
parle de ce qui se passe en prison ne
parlons pas de ce qu'on connaît pas et
ne jugeons pas il y a des gens bien en
prison
avec des permis de conduire parce qu'ils
avaient peur ils ont vendu du cannabis
ils regrette mais même le mec qui a
conduit avec un un faux permis citoyen
si
vous avez un perfection de parler
pendant 30 minutes
au premier qui rigole ou aimer le
moindre bruit c'est perdu je suis sûr à
10000% que avec les pipelettes qu'on a
ici avec les tarés qui font que hurler
jamais on va gagner 4 fois tu as pas
mangé depuis 10 jours ne ne nous manque
pas tu passes devant un étalage il y a
des fruits tu vas pêcher dans vos 10
jours il y a des chances il y a des
chances je vais te la faire autrement ta
femme et tes enfants ont faim tu vas pas
aller voler un kilo de pommes ne ment
pas
[Applaudissements]
de tous
j'ai rien dit je comprends pas entendu
le top départ du lion ben j'ai fait pas
tout le monde appelle alors là
franchement je suis choqué sous citoyen
je suis désolé avec l'intelligence que
vous avez je l'ai dit hier je le redis
vous êtes intelligent vous savez très
bien que c'est assimilé à sous homme et
bien voilà
tu es un ancien journaliste tu l'es
peut-être encore maintenant tu viens sur
un plateau de Télé 2 millions de
personnes te regardent tous les soirs
ton rôle c'est d'expliquer les choses
c'est d'expliquer les choses vous voyez
la France c'est de Gaulle mais c'est
aussi Patrick Sébastien c'est ce mélange
là que moi qui me touche viens me
rejoindre
tu sais que mes chansons les sardines
par exemple
faire voir des images tous les 15 jours
il y a un enterrement avec cette chanson
c'est que les gens se font enterrer avec
qu'est-ce qu'on est serrés au fond de
cette boîte
non mais
j'ai des manifestement la reine
d'Angleterre n'avait pas pris cette
option